hi my name is paul baldmanis i'm an
assistant professor in the division of
medical genetics at the university of
washington in seattle
and today i'm going to talk about
mechanistic insight into tandem repeat
expansions in amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis and i'm really excited to talk
today about some of the ongoing projects
in the lab identifying tandem repeat
expansions and their role in
evolutionary biology and
neurodegenerative diseases including als
canon repeat expansions are known to
cause over 40 neurological conditions
they've primarily been identified using
large multi-generational families
which helps identify a repeat segregated
from one generation to the next and as
you can see here
repeats can be present in all parts of
the gene including fibrin utr introns
coding regions and so on
and these all can lead to various
neurological conditions
however the 40 repeats that are
described here are just a subset of the
hundreds of thousands of tandem repeats
throughout the genome many of which may
cause or modify a disease in
the context of neurodegenerative disease
and one of the open questions about
these repeats is how do they expand how
do you go from a short
repeat copy with the
four or five cags in this example here
to an expanded allele do the repeats
expand at the beginning the middle or
the end and how many repeats are added
at any one particular time point
and in some cases it's not even the
repeat itself but it's actually the
internal sequence that's much more
critical in terms of disease
pathogenesis and so in this example with
this pedigree here you have these
individuals with over a thousand copies
of the pentane nucleotide repeat and
individuals unaffected with spinal
cerebral ataxia in this family have uh
this uh this pattern of a
pentanucleotide repeat uh that is a
a pure tract that's only in gray and
this is this atp ct sequence
however the four individuals with sda in
this family have this slippage from an
atp ct to an atpcc and this leads to the
the phenotype of this in this family and
the amount captured by whole genome
sequencing is just a subset of the whole
read
and i should point out that these are
these are identified through long read
sequencing approaches
so it emphasizes the point that as we're
expanding the ability to sequence the
genome using long read sequencing uh
we're identifying some of these repeat
expansions that were previously hidden
or intractable to short read whole
genome sequence
so with that in mind we set out to
identify potential tandem repeat
expansions in america lateral sclerosis
or als and als is also known as lou
gehrig's disease and is the result of
the degeneration of upper and lower
motor neurons in the brain stem spinal
cord and motor cortex
uh leading to loss of muscle innervation
paralysis and ultimately respiratory
failure right at the heart of adult life
and no drugs are able to prevent als
onset a couple can delay progression by
about a month or so um underscoring the
need for better therapeutics for this
devastating disorder
the genetic basis of als is starting to
become clearer uh there's about five to
ten percent of individuals with als that
have a family history of als so that is
uh one or more relatives with the the
with the disorder as well but as you can
see here some of the larger pedigrees
with 10 or more individuals affected
with als are the ones that are
used to identify
candidate genes and mutations
or pathogenic variants
in some of the diseases
in in als
and four genes
have been identified so the
uh that account for the majority of
familial als cases
um and really the past two decades has
seen tremendous progress in under in
identifying these genes and other
genetic risk factors
so the four genes are
superoxide dismutase or sod one tar dbp
which encodes the tdp-43 protein the
gene called fused and sarcoma
and interestingly the most common
genetic culprit is a g4 c2 nucleotide
repeat expansion in the intron of a gene
called c9 or f72 and this accounts for
about 40 to familial and 10
of sporadic als cases
and additional genetic contributions
have been identified through whole
genome sequencing studies
and whole genome association studies and
exome sequencing studies
revealing additional genetic culprits
and disease um often these are rare
variants that are identified in a
handful of of individuals or families or
in the case of gywa studies point to
loci
that are now being uh examined in more
detail to identify the causative variant
at these regions
but
as we're approaching 2020 and and and
beyond we're at this exciting time where
we have these new technologies available
to us where we can identify
novel risk factors and in particular
through single cell sequencing and long
read sequencing we can identify some of
these regions that really
could help explain some of the missing
credibility in als
and so
to to kind of speak about our work we
started out with one of the families
that initially had a fox variant and
we've taken a look at this family as
well and performed some genome-wise
streams to try to find if there was an
additional genetic modifier for this
region
and as you can see some of the
individuals
that are
white indicating they haven't developed
disease yet
i still have the variant
indicating that perhaps there's another
second hit or another genetic modifier
in this region
so from kind of old-school linkage
studies we'd actually mapped
this second region in this family to a
region on chromosome 18 used in sarcomas
on chromosome 16 and in this eight
chromosome 18 region all affected family
members share a four megabase segment of
dna
and the genome-wide significance of this
linkage was quite significant so we took
a look within this region to see whether
there were other risk factors that could
could help explain some of the missing
additional genetic risk factors in this
family
and uh this is just to kind of point out
uh by using both this chromosome 18
locus and the plus variant we could
start to explain some of the some of the
individuals that uh
had developed als but hadn't um
that are shaded in black um but did not
perhaps have a phosphate
and this uh this kind of like
combination is best exemplified by these
four siblings here
uh where you can see uh they have all
four possible genotypes either the fuss
variant
neither variant the chromosome 18 locus
or both and it was only the ones with
both that had that developed disease
and so in our search we came across this
human specific
uh tandem repeat expansion that each
copy of the repeat is 69 base pairs
and so
this is in the last intron of a gene
called wdr7
and each copy of the repeat actually
folds into this really interesting uh
hairpin-like structure where there's
regions of self-complementarity and then
a loop region and then
and then a gap and then another hairpin
the reference genome has about six
copies of copies of this repeat but
actually individuals
in that family had over uh over 30
copies of this repeat
again when this repeat is inserted into
rna folding algorithms it reveals this
really unique hairpin structure
of the centronic sequence
so the gene wdr7 itself encodes a
protein that localizes to synaptic
vessels uh vesicles involved in the
control of calcium-dependent exocytosis
of neurotransmitters
as well as acidification of endosomal
vesicles so all of these are relevant to
als etiology so we wanted to take a look
further
at
wdr7
function and kind of the evolution of
this repeat expansion
what really surprised us was that this
is a this is almost exclusively a human
specific repeat uh it's not present in
any lower mammals um
including uh including lemurs and and
other
non-primates
old world monkeys
starting with the squirrel monkey start
to
start to have about a 47 base pair
region of the repeat so it's about
two-thirds of the repeat
start to appear in these genomes
by the time you get by the time you get
to old world monkeys here starting with
the orangutan you actually jump to one
and a half copies of the repeat and by
the time you get to humans you have six
and a half copies up to 33 copies
uh in this uh in this als family so we
could track the
progression and the expansion of the
three feet uh throughout primate
evolution
um
but we were also interested kind of
beyond this uh beyond this role
you know what uh
is this a risk factor
in als beyond just the family
essentially and so to do this we were
curious uh to take a look at individuals
with sporadic als the large cohorts
and try to identify the repeat size to
see if we could find additional uh
individuals with high repeat copy member
and we're really fortunate in that we
were able to actually pcr amplify this
repeat we were able to design on the
left here in orange primers either at
the beginning or at the end of the
repeat
and we could actually then sequence
through
various copies of the repeat and shown
on the left is four copies with the
repeat
but on the right is a is a gel
uh of a pcr and you can see um each of
the rows is a different individual with
uh often two alleles of different
lengths
so we were able to actually
use this information to
pcr amplify and
run on the gel hundreds of als cases and
controls from the cory lcell repository
of bank dna samples and when we did this
we actually found an enrichment
of repeats that were 30 or more in
length in individuals with als
relative to controls uh we found cases
where there perhaps was like a
premutation uh just below that threshold
and we also found one individual at the
far right in orange with 86 copies of
the wdr7 repeat this is a female with a
without a family history of als who died
at the age of 72.
so combining all of these samples and
just measuring the largest or the
longest repeat
in each we actually could see that there
was a shift
to longer average repeat in als samples
to 17.7 copies versus 15.2 copies and
controls
and
what we were able to do was then use
this information to uh
and confirm this information using two
additional populations and we use full
genome sequencing um and read up to
estimate uh copy number uh in two
cohorts one from answer als and another
in samples from quebec canada
but so in our mind even though there's
control individuals have uh high numbers
of our high and repeat copies as well
there's a shift there's this kind of
modifying effect in the context of als
the second thing we wanted to do and
this relates to the
spinal fca uh pentanucleotide repeat
that i was showing earlier was to
determine whether there was any internal
repeat sequence that was different in
als so to do this we took those same
primers that we used to amplify wdr7 but
we added barcodes to the five prime and
three prime end and commentorial use of
those barcodes allowed us to actually
pcr amplify
144 individuals or 288 alleles in one
lane of tactile long lead sequencing
and we had a problem though
and the problem was that
how do we then take all that information
and encapsulate it and be able to align
it to identify if there was enrichment
and and one of the examples here is uh
is that 86 copies of the repeat where
you you see have
over and over again that repeat
expansion through the genetic sequence
and we needed to find a way to kind of
align that along with all some of the
other als individuals and controls that
we had
that underwent long green sequencing
so we used a couple of tricks
and the first thing that we wanted to do
was to look at the potential internal
sequence at each repeat unit so again
the wdr7 repeat is 69 nucleotides in
length and of those 69 nucleotides in
color you can see if a dot if there's a
dot it's the same as the consensus
sequence if there's a color it means
there's a base per change and there's
six positions where there are base pair
changes
throughout the repeat
and so what we were what we did was we
converted this to a single
color for each of the most common the 16
most common uh repeat sequences that we
observed and you can see each one has a
different combination of these internal
uh six uh variants that are present
when we did this we found that there
wasn't actually a difference between
each of the internal sequences between
als cases and controls but we could
still use this information to try to
design a pattern and convert some of
this information to a kind of a
color-coded map
so again from each individual we took we
identified the start of the repeat we
aligned this placed each repeat into a
separate row
converted this actually to a single
letter code to avoid some of the
complexities of this information and
converted that code to a color and the
reason why we chose these single letter
codes is that we could actually use
amino acid clustering alignment programs
to align some of the repeats to identify
patterns in their structure
and then the colors helped us visualize
things
rather than a series of letters together
on the slide we can kind of like
immediately kind of your eyes drawn to
some of the patterns in this sequence
and so this is a complex plot that we
put together but what you can see here
is that the repeat length is here on the
on the y-axis and individual alleles are
on the x-axis and starting on the left
you have about eight or so allele uh
individuals with you know um
five two three four and four copies of
the wdr7 repeats for each of them
we continue to do this iteratively um
and we when we were able to put it
together we saw this complex pattern of
uh of the repeats but we noticed
something and we were always kind of
sequencing this from the five prime to
three prime direction but in fact the
three prime uh region of the repeat had
a much more similar much more similarity
in terms of the colors that were present
and so when we realigned these on the
three prime end we started seeing these
amazing patterns and clusters of groups
of individuals it each had the same
a similar combination of the of the of
the wdr7 repeat and these were often
very much fixed at the
three prime end but then started to
diverge uh at the five prime end
and there were several kind of different
uh original clusters you can see ones
with a number of dark blue reeds numbers
with yellows and
purples and
and then dark red
and as every time we kind of looked at
this repeat we learned we learned more
information we started noticing patterns
that were emerging from this data one of
the first things we noticed was there
was this seemed to be this kind of
biphasic kind of um introduction in the
repeat so the repeats weren't showing up
one at a time but often in groups of two
and you can see that uh especially in
that in the middle of this repeat where
there is this dark red and light purple
uh clusters of repeats and so when we
analyze these iteratively across all of
the uh 288 alleles from 144 individuals
we saw this uh kind of periodicity of
the repeats where you're more likely to
see
uh
repeats the same repeat
two repeat units from each other four
repeat units six eight and so on than
you were to see the repeat unit
immediately adjacent to itself so
there's there's something about the two
repeat units together uh that
precipitates some of this expansion
we could see large duplication events in
some uh
in some of the cases you can see these
this group of about six repeat units
that were
that were copied several times into the
same in the same individual
and we can also see that again speaking
to the three point to five prime
directionality of the repeat uh whenever
we saw a new repeat unit and one that
wasn't part of that original 16 um these
ones we would color in black and these
ones would be up here these ones would
appear right at the five time end of the
repeat and then not only would they
appear once they would actually if they
if they appeared a second time like this
yellow black segment they actually
expanded in combination with that
previous repeat unit again suggesting
there's something unique about uh about
this 138 or so nucleotides of a
that was important for this expansion
event
the initial sequencing run that we had
performed was actually
selected for individuals with 20 repeats
or more because we were really concerned
about being able to amplify some of that
internal sequence with the really large
repeats once we started seeing those
patterns we then went and repeated the
tactile long read sequencing run with a
second cohort of individuals and the
second cohort um had
additional populations both with a.d and
control but also individuals from the
thousand genomes population uh allowing
for kind of a more diverse cohort of
individuals uh
looking at repeat extensions
what we noticed because we didn't and in
this case we didn't size select so we
were noticing several alleles on the
left that were of the shorter nature but
we also saw that exact same pattern that
we saw before where you had these
clusters of the same kind of
segments of repeats indicating that
the alignment that we put together was
reproducible
and then using some of these thousand
genomes population
samples from worldwide populations we
could start to see patterns emerging
from some of the groups so for instance
it locks here um samples from africa on
the left and samples that were outside
of africa that had the kind of the same
uh original base structure and then
halfway through there's this divergence
point between pink and purple alleles
and african samples maintain their
trajectory from there on in out
and non-africans have a different um
alleles that are added
uh suggesting that perhaps there was a
an evolutionary time point when this uh
this breakpoint occurred and we saw the
same phenomenon in uh repeat expansions
that were specific to han chinese um
individuals where they had
expanded using their own combination of
these internal repeat sequences
so we think this is a fascinating kind
of
tool that can be used to kind of track
evolutionary expansion of
some of these tandem repeats across
different populations
from a multi-generational standpoint
within one pedigree we can use the
information to again
track segregation from parents to
children
and because we can combine this with the
internal sequence information we can
actually find individuals with similar
length
alleles but actually different internal
sequence within them
and then another cool thing that we
could do was then because we had all
this information that we gathered from
longread sequencing we could go back to
short read sequencing and whole genome
sequencing to try to determine and
predict uh what alleles were present in
certain populations and in particular we
were interested in ancient populations
like denisovans and neanderthals
um and so as you can see here this is an
igb plot
where the top panel
is is the alignment of short reads to
the wdr7 intron and in the middle is the
region with the vntr and you can see
there's a very strong pile up a short
reef at that vmtr itself uh suggesting
that it's much larger than the reference
gene human genome which has six copies
and conversely neanderthals uh have more
reads at the surrounding genomic region
but a paucity of reads at the vntr
itself suggesting that perhaps it is a
shorter
repeat than than in the human presence
genome and in fact we can actually go
and identify what
because of our with with that internal
sequence what the actual repeat units
are so we can see that there are four
different repeat units present in the
neanderthals and so they either have a
combination of one and three copies or
two and two copies of the repeat and
then denise evans we can map the number
of repeats
and the number of counts of repeat copy
numbers and actually use this
information to try to
reconstruct potentially their
their ancestral
allele at wdrs at the wdr7 locus
and
beyond this one repeat we were really
interested you know can we generalize
this information across the um
you know the 55 000 variable number
tandem repeats in the human genome and
variable number meaning uh repeats with
the
internal sequence
composition seven nucleotides or greater
and so for this we took advantage of a
couple of publications from the uh from
the group of evan eichler um
including this one here that maps uh
variable number 10 and retreats across
the genome and we can see there's a lot
of them in green that are uh that
cluster around telomeres or sub-temp
telomeric regions but we also had enough
within genes and around genes that we
could uh extract the information and
take a look
at whether they expanded in a manner
similar to the wdr7 repeat
and our selection criteria were
ultimately around 400 repeats that are
human-specific with a single site in the
genome and a repeat unit 25 nucleotides
or greater
and what we were able to do was take
advantage of
15
individuals again from the thousand
genomes population sample set that had
undergone long read phase sequencing
and these individuals had
aligned here on the y-axis had various
copies of some of the repeats that we
were taking a look at
and so each kind of uh
each of each row here represents a
different individual and they're
combinations of repeat lengths
in this case for a 41 nucleotide uh
repeat unit in a in the intron of a gene
called nwd2
and as you can see when we kind of like
took a look at some of the um the repeat
structure in the organization this is
kind of what we were expecting to see is
that again similar to wdr7 we
color-coded each of the different
repeat units
so in light blue you have
one sequence that is repeated several
times and in purple you'll have a repeat
unit again of that 41 nucleotides with
maybe a base pair change somewhere
throughout it and we can see both
combinations of the light blue and
purple um throughout the repeat and
lengths that span between
less than 10 to over 40 copies of that
repeat
so again it suggests to us that wdr7 is
is not alone in terms of its variability
extreme variability in terms of length
however this repeat itself was much more
pure in terms of the the internal
sequence there was there were fewer
nucleotide variants than the 16 or so we
observed in wdr7
when we examined
additional repeats
the npr repeats
we found other categories of kind of
dormant repeat units
in this case again it's this is a 41
base pair repeat in a in a gene called
loc 102
725 191
that
primarily had about 30 copies of this
repeat you can see there's a lot more
colors that are present that means that
there are a lot more internal nucleotide
variants that each copy of that 41 base
pair
repeat unit however whatever expansion
was taking place and nucleotide changes
that were taking place throughout that
extension um were occurring uh
much earlier on so as the repeat had
seemed to become fixed in modern humans
and a third category of repeats that we
observed which was probably less than 10
percent of the time but we saw other
repeats where there were
different alleles that were present and
and major alleles that were present that
had different combinations of length and
internal sequence so the first uh three
copy three individuals here had one set
of uh colors indicating kind of what a
fixed kind of group of of alleles and
then the bottom side of another uh
cluster and in the middle you actually
had this individual that had a kind of a
switch from one allele to the other so
some kind of a
recombination event
so these were the three kind of main
categories of tandem repeats we we
observed when looking at long-range
sequencing
um but we also found some really
interesting outliers and and unique kind
of nuggets in terms of uh their their
properties and in this case this is a
it's a 33 base pair repeat unit in the
three prime utr of a gene called bps53
and it has three separate segments
within its uh internal tendon repeat so
the first segment is fixed in length but
variable at each comp at each copy of
the repeat so each copy of the repeat
had a different internal sequence
and then you had a second segment where
there was mostly a pure sequence but
some variability in length
apart from these few individuals with a
kind of a a darker blue color
and then you have this uh really
interesting third segment um where there
were
combinations of three repeat units
together that were expanding and and
quite a bit of diversity in terms of the
repeat length
so that segment three is the one that
seems to be actively expanding and one
that we're really interested in
determining you know um as as you know
as we identify more individuals you know
what accounts for some of this
variability and length and why is it
expanding again in combinations of three
repeat units or about 100
base pairs
versus the the wd or 7 repeats it seems
to be expanding in two repeat copies
and we could find again that we could
really kind of use this information to
then narrow down exactly the components
involved with the repeat expansions um
as we kind of sequence as we analyzed
more and more individuals using long
read sequencing so again this is a this
is a repeat in the gene called slp 22a1
where you have
a bit more than 40 copies of that repeat
in some individuals
and you can see here there are gaps so
these gaps in white represent uh kind of
deletion events that are that are
present uh that are
or the deletions that are present in
certain individuals
we also have duplication events so you
can see starting with orange
um up until purple and and light purple
colors this event this whole block gets
duplicated in a series of individuals
and we see once that first duplication
event takes place we actually see a
second duplication event in this
individual up here because now the
orange allele has been placed next to
the to the light purple one and you see
a second event where they've added
another segment of about
six or seven repeat unit
numbers at the top there so you can kind
of use this to progressively track how a
repeat is expanding amongst these
individuals
and then finally using whole genome
sequencing we could actually identify
regions uh much larger much more complex
repeats that uh
differed in length in in hundreds of
repeat copies
and so to do this we took a look at
short read sequence data identified
repeats that were much more
much longer in length in for instance
african samples versus
admixed american samples
and prop 1 is an example of a repeat in
this case actually that's uh in
longer in african samples r1 is a
as a repeat that on average has a much
longer
length in add mixed americans
and then we could uh using long read
sequencing identify again that internal
sequence and uh of each repeat unit um
and the colors that represented some of
the internal uh variability in the in
these alleles and so a number of the
individuals with from the african
samples uh had
uh were appearing at the top of this
chart where they were only blue and at
the bottom were samples from european
and ad next americans where you have
these uh expansions in combinations with
2kb blocks
um so as we're getting more and more
long-range sequencing information we can
get a good idea of
um how these repeats are expanding the
internal sequence that is combined along
with this and uh and and understand kind
of some of these uh some of the
differences in amongst humans
so in summary i want to say that uh you
know we're really interested and we can
we truly believe that long-range
sequencing of tandem repeats can provide
a lot of information about
both human evolutionary
events but also risk factors for
neurodegenerative disease and we believe
that
vntr expansions standard repeat
extensions and als
are cannot can
represent novel disease risk factors
not only in als but also in other
neurodegenerative diseases as well
and and further analysis of the internal
sequence of these repeats can help
reveal mechanisms of tendon repeat
expansion
so with that i'd like to thank members
of the lab past and present
as well as funding sources and our
collaborators at the university of
washington and mcgill university thank
you very much